[Musique]
ce bâtiment Maison de l'étudiant donc a
été pensé pour être un lieu pour
l'ensemble des associations étudiantes
mais également pour réunir tous les
services qui ont att trait à la vie
étudiante dès leur arrivée à
l'université au rez-de-chaussée don donc
c'est toute la partie donc salle de
représentation du théâtre du cinéu des
[Musique]
séminaires la salle de multiactivité
pour le
sport et puis vous avez la la salle
d'art plastique pour tous les ateliers
atelier sculpture atelier peinture et
dessin tous les services que les
étudiants peuvent trouver dans cette
maison d'étudiant c'est aussi bien donc
le service du sub service universitaire
donc de médical de prévention de la
promotion de la santé donc tous les
étudiants pourront venir à ce service et
avec leur carte Vitale donc avoir leur
visite médicale il y a également le
service d'orientation d'insertion
professionnelle le service
d'accompagnement des étudiants en
situation dehicap le service de
l'assistante sociale du CROUS le bureau
des enquêtes et analyses et puis bah au
premier étage on a tout le service de la
vieud les relations internationales et
bien sûr toute la pépinière associative
he et chaque chaque association qui a
agréée qui a fait une demande de de
bureau à un bureau avec une
réserve tous les nouveaux étudiants donc
qui arrivent à l'université viennent
directement à la Maison de l'étudiant
pour donc finaliser leur inscription
administrative généralement ces
inscriptions administratives se font par
internet mais ils ont quelques
difficultés donc ils viennent finaliser
leur inscription et et lorsqu'ils
arrivent sur cette maison d'étudiant ils
ont l'ensemble des services puisque le
service de la vie étudiante leur a mis
en place un guichet unique sur ce
guichet unique qui trouve tous les
services aussi bien les mutuels que des
comptes donc un service bancaire
l'Office de Tourisme donc de de
saint-grantin en iveline donc vraiment
tous les
services utiles le service logement
également qui est là donc pour répondre
bah à des étudiants français des
étudiants étrangers qui sont à la
recherche aussi de logement
[Musique]